now we should be able to find the most
appropriate URL that our app should use
based on the ux wireframes we saw
earlier we want the weather forecast for
a week's worth of data given a certain
postal code for the purposes of this
quiz in our example code that will be
showing you will be using the Mountain
View postal code which is 9 for 0 for 3
by all means you should use the postal
code for your own location or you can
use city name or latitude longitude
coordinates if it doesn't find your
location based on postal code try using
postal code followed by a comma followed
by the country code see the discussion
forum for more examples next we want the
response from the server to be in JSON
format and we also want the temperatures
to be reported in metric units we choose
metric for doing the query but our UI
will be able to display Celsius or
Fahrenheit based on user preferences and
we'll just do the conversion ourselves
enter the URL in the box that fulfills
these requirements